there can't be a greater high than on
oscar night when you look into [ __ ]
christian bale's eyes and leonardo
dicaprio and you go you two [ __ ] i
just beat you i mean what is a bigger
what is a bigger high than that i mean
honestly i mean you must have been on
cloud nine just you know just [ __ ]
was it's like it's like you smacked them
right in the head right it was beautiful
it was beautiful
do you ever like in the middle of the
night do you ever call up leonardo
dicaprio i beat you and then hang up the
[ __ ] phone
that's what i would do if i was you yeah
you know me always leaving him messages
[Laughter]
it was a beautiful night it really was
you know one of the cool things that
came from that um
besides the obvious was you know i got
three children 12 10
7 and you know if you got children you
know one of the things we try to teach
them is the value of delayed
gratification well i remember after that
my children going like what'd you win
the trophy for
and i said well you remember a year and
a half ago when y'all said we were
working and pot you'd wake up and pop i
would already be gone to work and i'd
get home
and you said papa i look like a giraffe
i was really skinny and they're like
yeah and i go well
what pop i was doing each day when you
would wake up when i was gone the work i
was doing then a year and a half later
my peers
deemed it excellent work and gave me a
trophy for and so they it was the best
version for them getting the click that
oh you can do things today and be
rewarded tomorrow if you do them well it
was really it was really cool lesson you
wanted that then
would you feel okay if your kids became
actors would you uh or would you want
something different for them oh sure no
i i i love uh acting and it's been very
good to me i will say this you know we
were talking about it earlier about what
hollywood can do to you i went out there
when i was 21.
i don't think i would have been ready
when i was 18.
um
i had a sense i didn't know
i wasn't fully secure in who i was but i
had a very good sense of who i wasn't
and who i didn't want to be uh before i
went out there and so hollywood's not a
place to go find yourself
at the same time it's a place where you
can be anybody you want
um right it's not a place to go find
yourself i would want my children to
have a sense of themselves and a sense
of who they did not want to be before
they go out there because again it's all
the yeses too many options can make a
tyrant of any of us and i've been guilty
of it so guilty it's be good to go to
hollywood if my kids ever wanted to to
get have a bearing on who they are and
who they are not before they go out
there
you